the quality of your life is shaped
fundamentally by
certain opinions that you hold
predominantly your value judgments the
things that you value and the things
that you despise are going to shape your
character and therefore the quality of
your life
are you marcus aurelius's number one fan
do you think or do you think that you're
the most most educated on him or one of
the most educated on him that's alive at
the moment
i yeah i mean it doesn't seem like that
much of a break because i've spent so
much time having to read his stuff i'm
probably i must be one of the people in
the world that knows the most about
marcus aurelius now just because i spent
so much time writing stuff about him
and uh i kind of thought i learned a lot
about him and then obviously when you
write
other stuff like right from a different
perspective the graphic novel i suddenly
had to think what did this look like and
what did that look like and so it made
me explore his life from a bit of a
different perspective had to visualize
it more and i thought well now i know
everything i need to know about him but
then when i did the more academic
biography
uh that was a more rigorous standard in
a way and i thought no i'm now doing
research that's even deeper than i did
before
so
apparently there's always more to learn
so uh marcus aurelius there can't be
that much left emperor of rome
but followed a greek born philosophy
why yeah
well i'll let's get into some obscure
stuff then i
i can't be 100 sure but i'm going to
start speculating chris right
i reckon it was to do with his mum
partly that's one reason so his mum his
father passed away when marcus was we
think about three or four years old and
so he was brought up to a large extent
although not exclusively by his mother
now his mother was a very wealthy and
powerful woman she was a construction
magnate believe it or not and we know
that because we have hundreds of bricks
with her name stamped on them she owned
a
a brick and tile factory and clay fields
that were used in construction so she's
very wealthy and powerful women not like
we might have kind of assumed
you know in uh in roman times and she
had a kind of
she seems to have had an intellectual
circle that surrounded her like a salon
of intellectuals at their house
and so she was a very well educated
woman here's a bit of trivia for you
marcus cornelius frontal
who is marcus's latin rhetoric tutor and
was considered the greatest roman orator
since cicero which is you know quite an
accolade we have a letter from him where
he says to marcus he's writing to marx's
mother in greek and he says marcus kind
of pathetically could you check
my grammar and my vocabulary and stuff
to make sure that it's okay before your
mom reads it
so fronto one of the greatest
intellectuals of the era is kind of
intimidated by marcus's mother
that's cool
that is cool and so because she was
really into greek culture um and
literature i think she brought up her
son
to be integrity philosophy and that kind
of led to stoicism also the other this
is a real deep dive
roman uh
matriarchs were are believed to have
been the ones that were mainly
responsible for choosing the tutors that
were employed and marcus had an unusual
number of stoic philosophy tutors so he
got into stoicism himself but we also
have to assume that his family were kind
of steering him in that direction and it
was probably his mum that picked those
stoic tutors for him
what was the culture of rome like uh
were there philosophy were the roman
philosophers as well obviously
apart from marcus what was the
difference between them and the stoics
i mean the culture was the
marcus was living through a cultural
movement called the second sophistic so
the softest people may have heard of is
these kind of
quasi-philosophers or intellectuals the
uh socrates was kind of jousting with
intellectually he was a critic of the
sophists but there was a resurgence of
popularity in the roman empire of the
sophists so these were greek orators and
speechwriters and generally
intellectuals who came over and they
were viewed as exotic and they became
very trendy for centuries in the roman
empire and marcus kind of grew up in the
middle of that so hadrian
who was a huge figure in marcus's life
he hadrian became marcus's adoptive
grandfather and marcus was brought into
hadrian's villa and raised in his
household for around about six months
towards the end of hadrian's life hayden
kind of wanted to be a sophist like he
loved he spent a lot of time in athens
he left he did a lot of construction in
athens like he saw himself as an
intellectual and surrounded himself with
these sophists and marcus grew up in
this kind of i guess we would say sort
of pretentious
intellectual culture
and his mum was kind of connected with
that the most influential greek orator
the most influential intellectual in a
sense of the period was a guy called
herod's atticus who's famous now in
greece
because um
the four fighters
performed the concert at a building
called the odeon of a roadies atticus
it's a famous building on the side of
the acropolis which still exists i've
been to it still yeah you've been there
and like uh you know staying and like
brian you know all these kind of
musicians performed there now
and uh
rhody's atticus was like a billionaire
and a celebrity orator like a rock star
of the period he was also a really
horrible man with a really bad temper he
was raised for a time in the same
household as marxia released his mother
like we know that's a little kind of
fragment of a clue so she knew
the leading softest of the era so how's
that this guy that we think of as a
stoic or typically critics of these kind
of pretentious intellectuals his mum
grew up in the same household as the
most influential and famous sophist of
them all and he became a family friend
sort of a kind of friend of me in a way
for the the rest of marcus's life at one
point he lunged at marcus like he was
going to throttle him or something and
he was nearly executed by the praetorian
prefect but marcus stood up and and told
his gods to stand down i suppose if you
are
if if the person that is at the absolute
tip of the spear of
the cool movement of the time
also happens to be a bit of a dick
that's a pretty good
excuse to not
want your son to grow up like that
that's a good description i mean what
have we got against the road he's like
he did that horrible thing the athenians
hated them they were always trying to
sue him in court
um he
he kind of
went he was tried because he was accused
of kicking his pregnant wife to death
although he was acquitted of that but
there's a kind of stigma that hung over
him like he kind of managed to dodge a
bullet they are um so the irony is that
we know
here's another cool bit of trivia like
we know that herod's atticus had read
epictetus
and he kind of liked to quote him
sometimes like the sophists would often
quote philosophers but they kind of
appropriated it because it sounded cool
like they didn't really live like
philosophers like it was more about you
know they literally
like social media today they would give
speeches where they tried to win
uh the biggest round of applause like
getting the most likes or something like
that they were celebrities so we know
epic erodes attic has criticized the
stoics because he said they espouse
insensibility he goes they root out the
most kind of vibrant emotions and you
don't want to end up like one of these
guys like a robot or whatever and the
story said that's not at all what we're
about
so this guy that's saying the stoics are
too unemotional i think marcus looked at
him and said dude i don't want to be
like you though like you've got an
appallingly bad temper and like you know
i think
the one thing that really shaped marcus
was seeing these guys side by side and
thinking this dude that's saying embrace
your passions and all that is actually a
horrible violent person and these other
guys that say no you have to learn to
understand and to master your passions
marcus loved and really admired those
dudes and just in a personal level much
more than you know he ever warmed
his atticus
what was the story of how meditations
was actually written it was given it was
even a different name when it was first
written right
yeah it's called well the earliest
manuscript was headed to himself
so it may be that that's the title that
it was originally given which is kind of
interesting because
for ancient philosophers would sometimes
say that to learn philosophy is to learn
to discourse to talk with yourself
which is a really from a cognitive
therapy point of view you know i'm a
cognitive behavioral psychotherapist
this idea that it's about learning how
to talk to yourself rationally is a
really cool concept and in the
meditations marcus kind of has this
recurring phrase where he says every
morning say to yourself so the book
consists of lots of things that he's
telling himself to say to himself so
it's a very appropriate heading for it
how it was written
we believe
that it was written
pretty much coinciding
with
the first marker manic war
and i it happens to be just after
marcus's main philosophy tutor junius
rusticus dies
so i'm very tempted to visualize again
when you do the graphic novel you're
trying to like visualize these things
you think look this guy's just died that
he's his main tutor he's just left rome
pretty much for the first time to go to
austria and this climate that he finds
very harsh with the military it's the
first time he's really been like
stationed himself with the military like
this like a real fish out of water
suddenly and he does not have
he may have had some philosophers with
him but he did not really have this kind
of circle of philosophers that he would
have had at rome and we know marcus
wright uh like to write letters so
imagine that he was probably writing
letters to some of the philosophers that
he was friends with i wish we still had
those we have letters to his rhetoric to
talk where they cannot gossip about
philosophy or that and stuff
but i imagine that when rustic has died
marcus was left thinking who am i going
to talk to for about philosophy now
and if he'd been writing to him it would
have been very natural for him to think
maybe i need to carry on writing about
philosophy but instead of addressing
letters to rusticus there's no passed
away i should write to myself
and i would like to imagine that some of
the things that marcus is saying in the
meditations must be
things that he heard in lectures or that
he'd read in books or that he'd
discussed and maybe written about in
letters to rusticus and uh the various
other stoic turtles that he had
how much do you think is original
thought then
and how much do you think is repurposed
from people
that or or places that we perhaps don't
have access to anymore
that's a really good question
and the short answer is
we just will die not knowing chris
probably we'll never be able to figure
that out
though i'll tell you some really cool
trivia about it the person that marx
early is quotes most often is epictetus
but he clearly loves epictetus and he
says at the beginning that one of the
biggest moments in his life was when
junice rusticus gave him a copy from his
personal library of the discourses of
epictetus now the discourses of
epictetus are quite long they're like
four volumes but one ancient source says
there were originally eight volumes so
half of them have gone missing right
they were misplaced some you know
sometime over the centuries annoyingly
now marcus quotes stuff that's in the
discourses they also quote stuff from
epictetus that we've never heard before
so what's really cool is to imagine that
marcus aurelius had read the four
missing volumes of epic tcc he knows
even more about this dude than we do and
so like because they don't use quotation
marks and they don't cite things
um
certainly marcus writing informally
doesn't do anything like that he
occasionally will say as plato said or
as epic titus said so there's a clue but
some of the things he said look like
they're quotes and they maybe maybe some
of the stuff that we attribute to marx
aurelius is actually stuff that
epictetus said that he's just copying
down into his nose you know but hasn't
it doesn't have quotation marks around
it for all we know
are you familiar with churchillian drift
do you know what that is
no i've not had that expression before
you need it you need it in your life so
you'll have heard a lot of people
attribute quotes to i i i think it was
churchill that said this thing it's uh
the
phenomenon whereby
quotes that are kind of difficult to
attribute
end up
moving slowly over time toward being
churchill you could also have like an
einsteinian drift as well i think like
einstein and churchill i i don't know
who said this quote so i'd better say
churchill said it because it probably
was and what you have here is like an
uh aurelius ian
drift
in that he
because so much less of his work has
been lost than other people around that
time
or at least because so much of it has
been preserved um that means if he's
been condensing down other people's work
maybe he is taking
a license for other people's stuff
i mean it could be the loads of the
meditations is just quotes from all the
books for all we know like i don't think
it all is because some of it's kind of
personal to him and i'll tell you i'll
tell you another really cool piece of
priesthood trivia first of all just an
aside about this church hilly and drift
you know i just to interject a warning
to your viewers right
the internet is absolutely awash replete
i hate to replete
with misattributed quotes and there are
a bunch that people attribute to marcus
aurelius over and over again that
happens so often that you then
eventually they they find a way into
books and so you buy books what what are
the most
said that what are the most
misattributed marcus aurelius quotes
what the most does does one that says
everything you see is just a perspective
or something like that which
is doesn't even make sense semantically
you don't you don't see a perspective
you see through a perspective isn't it
i'm like jeez marcus would never write
that that's nonsense but like uh
he wouldn't say that anyway because it's
kind of extreme relativism and marcus
would say now that might be true of some
things but like you know the mark is
believed that there are
certainties in life like he thought
there were moral certainties in life
now i was going to say something of
i've forgotten what i was going to say
chris about uh epictetus so maybe it
doesn't matter the church chili and
drift we were talking about
and the all the quotes that are
attributed to
marcus aurelius not necessarily from
them that was very common in the ancient
world you know the
ideas end up we only have about one
percent of ancient literature surviving
today so of course we're probably
misattributing loads of ideas
is the whole universe's change and life
itself is but what you deem it is that
him
i you know i'm going to say yes and no
like because i think he would say
himself that what he's doing there i
remember what i was going to tell you
actually it relates to this this is
you've given me a really good example
um
in greek that's just like six words it's
like really really concise right
and
he you can tell from the context that
what he's saying is the universe's
change is him referring to heraclitus
and life is opinion is him referring to
epictetus so he's trying to sum up these
his two favorite philosophers i said
earlier he may his favorite person to
quote is epictetus his second favorite
person to quote is heraclitus and so
these are like his two favorite
philosophers and he's trying to sum up
the their philosophy and just like as
few words as possible
um
and uh so he can memorize it really
easily this is a kind of like he's
making slogans for himself this is the
thing that the stoix would do so by the
universe is change he means what we call
pantare everything flows
like uh this kind of doctrine of
impermanence that you find in the
pre-socratic philosopher heraclitus that
historically loved life is opinion is a
bit more obscure it needs to be unpacked
about what he does not mean everything
is just subjective he's talking about
when epictetus says
uh it's not things that upset us but
rather our opinions about them what he
means is the quality of your life
is shaped fundamentally by
certain opinions that you hold
predominantly your value judgments so
what he's saying is the things that you
value and the things that you despise
are going to shape your character and
therefore the quality of your life so it
unfortunately you lose
some meaning by trying to simplify and
abbreviate things that's what he's doing
he's trying to make it more memorable
but he's ended up saying something that
people are bound to into africa well you
have to sacrifice uh context uh for
brevity right this is what i mean i'm a
big fan of naval ravicant i'm not sure
if you've come across him
no i haven't very very cool guy so he's
a
vc angel investor but also
i i guess he'd class himself as a sort
of garage philosopher as well and he's
very very pithy so he's like an aphorism
uh factory and he's constantly putting
out these really really cool short sort
of aphoristic things and
he says basically the same thing look
the point is for this to kind of be like
um
like a buoy
in the water and you know that below
that there's tons and tons of stuff it's
kind of like a just a little mental
trigger look
this is the thing that you got to
remember there's a big concept it's not
worth just knowing the thing you've got
to know the concept but in order to
remind you of the concept here's the
thing that sits above the water of it
epictetus says almost exactly the same
thing in one of his discourses he says
if you ask us what the goal of life is
we'll say it's living in a chord with
nature or he says something else
actually and he says but then if you ask
us what does living mean and what does
nature mean it's going to take a lot
longer to unpack like those concepts so
he says you can condense things down
into a short slogan like just a few
words but then you're going to have to
explain what those words mean in order
to avoid confusion it's basically the
same idea because it really clearly and
it reminds me of like the other little
bit of trivia i was going to tell you
and this is just like a cool thing for
people that are interested in the
meditations right
so first of all that background uh i i
meet a surprising number of people who
think that we don't know anything about
marcus aurelius which is really weird
because he was a big deal back in the
day and one of the reasons i've written
about him is we know more about marxist
relays than we do about almost any other
ancient philosopher certainly far more
than we know about any other stoic
because he was a roman emperor so we
have like three major surviving
histories of his reign we have a bunch
of archaeological evidence and
inscriptions we have references to him
and loads of other writings we have a
record of his legal rescripts like his
uh his legal um agenda uh from the laws
that he passed in roman legal digests
but we also have a cache of letters that
were found in the 19th century between
marcus and marcus cunningham's frontal
his rhetoric tutor that mentioned
earlier and some people are disappointed
by those letters because
they're kind of mainly chit chatting
they talk about their aches and pains
and the weather and stuff like that
there's not a lot of philosophy in them
but at one point and frontal tends to
talk about these rhetoric exercises that
he's setting marcus like how to practice
um writing powerful speeches and how to
phrase things effectively and stuff
but at one point
frontal sets this exercise for marcus
and he basically has this thing where
marcus is trying to decide whether he
wants to spend his time studying
rhetoric or studying philosophy and
frontal is kind of kind of struggling to
persuade marcus um in order to retain
his status that core is his main tutor
he's kind of he was in competition he
says with rusticus like to be marcus's
main tutor as he gradually got older and
shifted more towards philosophy and what
fronto says is very interesting he says
basically that philosophers come up with
these insights
that are kind of obscure by their very
nature so you think very deeply about
things you're going to come up with
stuff that's kind of hard to put into
words it's going to seem like any
original thought it's going to be
difficult to articulate at first and he
says so the philosophers end up saying
weird stuff like they make up
jargon and things like that and they say
things are kind of obscure and he says
if you want to really understand things
and if you want to communicate them
effectively you have to study rhetoric
as well
like you're gonna have to figure out how
to take these paradoxical ideas
and put them into play in english
basically for your own benefit as well
as the benefit of other people and he
tells marcus you should take these
insights and practice paraphrasing them
repeatedly so thinking of different
metaphors different words that you could
use to try and get the meaning across
you think oh that's cool it's kind of
like a rhetoric exercise he this also
shows him trying to figure out a way
that he can hang on to his position in
court so marcus don't just leave me and
go off and do philosophy you need
rhetoric and philosophy he wants to say
but also the really cool thing about it
is when scholars first read that letter
um and he returns to a few times in
other places
they thought how weird is this because
that looks like that's what he's doing
in the meditations
my in the meditations he's taking these
paradoxical ideas and it looks like he's
pat he repeats them over and over again
like he's paraphrasing them it looks
like he's doing this thing that fronto
tells him to do where he's turning an
idea over and over in his mind and
trying to articulate it in different
ways so he understands it from different
perspectives
that's the problem i think a lot of
people have with the social media
twitter verse when it comes to deploying
wisdom that it's all uh all front and uh
no substance right that people can use
fancy rhetoric and fluent talking to
cover up the fact that there's actually
it's a baseless argument that they're
putting across so there isn't anything
deeper than that fluency is used as a
proxy for truthfulness or insight
yeah it sucks we need to there's
something about that like social media
is awesome like but all good things kind
of have their pros and cons right and
one of the disadvantages of it is that
it really seems to i think there are
features of social media that have made
people more angry and confrontational
and it seems to have kind of really
damaged people's ability to engage in
reasoned arguments somehow
like you see way more kind of fallacies
like ad hominem attacks sweeping
generalizations and stuff and the
internet then you'd normally expect to
see just in an everyday conversation
with other people i think somehow it
allows people to get away with saying
irrational stuff more than you know
you'd be challenged perhaps a little bit
more or in a more effective way in a
normal face-to-face conversation
there's another thing that happens which
you know socrates
said an odd thing about the sophists
a lot here's about a trivia not a lot of
people know about socrates right sockets
used to pretend that he had a bad memory
he was kind of famous for it he'd be
like oh i've got this really bad memory
and it was part of the socratic irony it
was feigned and the reason he did it was
because the sophists were known for
giving really long elaborate speeches
right and one of the risks of that is
that often people disguise the weakest
part of their argument by taking it for
granted it's like an unspoken premise
and then they'll build on it and build
on it and build on it until everybody's
kind of forgotten that the foundation
was nonsense to begin with right
and so socrates would say oh interrupt
this office all the time he wouldn't let
them go for more than a sentence or two
and he'd say well hang on a minute let's
just check
like your starting point before we go
any further and that really aggravated
them like it was one of the things he
was kind of known for and it didn't
sound cool to listen to people thought
well this office are more entertaining
you can be passive you just sit there
and let it kind of wash over you like
this colorful like emotional speech and
stuff and socrates kept interrupting
them at the beginning and say and not
even letting them get started because he
said but the thing that you're assuming
right from the very beginning like do we
know for certain that that's absolutely
true or you've given this big speech
about justice but you haven't explained
what justice means like let's stop and
just define you know the concepts that
you're using before we even go any
further
i've got a quote from zeno that may have
had churchillian drift on it so i'm
going to stress test it with you about
this exact thing
long wordy sophistic uh philosophical
discussions were popular in ancient
roman greece zeno the founder of
stoicism took a totally different
approach and was super concise when
someone complained that his
philosophical arguments were very abrupt
zeno agreed and replied if i could i'd
abbreviate the syllables as well
yeah and where he gets that from is the
spartans so we say that someone is
laconic
if they're very kinetius and abrupt and
laconia is the region like the county or
whatever where the city of sparta was
located so it means laconic just means
spartan right the spartans were known
for speaking in this very concise very
brief way and the stoics and socrates
were kind of known for modeling
themselves a bit on certain aspects of
spartan culture there's a really good
anecdote about a sophist and the spartan
king
so there was a a sophist and this must
have been relatively unusual he went to
sparta and he spoke to spartan king i
guess the spartan king was like i'm just
going to find out what these guys are
like you know i thought i'd check it out
so this guy is invited to the court and
he gives a big elaborate speech and then
he says at the end of it to the king uh
what did you
you know what did you think of that
um and the king says well it went on so
long
by spartan standards he goes i can't
even remember the beginning
and therefore i didn't understand the
middle and so i can't agree with your
conclusion
like which is a very socratic sounding
things to say
you know he wants to kind of go right
back to the beginning of the speech
and say let's just roll it back a bit
and look at where you started i mean the
easiest way to explain that as like i
said earlier people talk about courage
or justice or wisdom
they say a lot of things there's a lot
of hot air but socrates would say well
hang on a minute we need to define what
you mean by those words before we start
using them
otherwise we kind of get lost in the
weeds and we get lots of weeds all the
time on the internet yeah i wonder why
you were talking about social media i
wonder why it is
that
people are able to make
more obvious errors uh online maybe part
of it is that
these immediate social cost
of doing something like you would see it
in someone's face
if you start to stray or make a fallacy
you'll see someone go like that almost
immediately whereas on the internet
you're a little bit more detached it's
bizarre because on the internet
certain things are scrutinized more
because the bandwidth is lower and it's
this sort of staccato i say a thing then
you prepare and you say a thing then i
prepare and i say a thing so some of the
stuff is more scrutinized but some of
the stuff is a lot less scrutinized and
unable to be sort of slipped in a little
bit more easily especially when emotions
are running high what do you think uh
what do you think marcus aurelius would
say about the current state of the
internet and social media and tribalism
and stuff like that i think he'd have a
lot to say about it and it may surprise
people i mean he'd say talk about many
aspects some of the things that you've
just touched on
um he'd say maybe on social media people
are less able to interrupt you maybe
also you can you're not seeing the
facial expression and stuff you can also
just ignore them
there are many people that pissed off on
social media and never read any of the
responses
like so they're just kind of like
spewing stuff out but they're not really
i in psychotherapy you know that to me
sets alarm bells ringing like because
people kind of need the socializing
effect of getting feedback from other
people we need critics we need
disagreement in order to knock the rough
edges off our thinking basically you
know but there are some people are so
kind of narcissistic or like they just
want to put stuff out and and not get
any kind of feedback on it and which is
the opposite in the sense of the peer
review
like uh method and science like science
is all about stuff out there and then
you let everyone tear it to shreds and
that's kind of like how we learn stuff
but there are definitely intellectuals
that avoid doing that like the plague
like they don't present their ideas at
conferences you know like they don't
engage with our critics and stuff like
that one of the things the story is the
store is named after this public space
in the agora when the other philosophers
had kind of retreated to some extent to
these more private schools outside the
city walls the stories went no we're
going back to where socrates did
philosophy out in the marketplace so
that anybody can come along and tell us
that they think we're talking rubbish
like and they can pose in our ideas
because we we want to engage
with other people who want to to hear
their criticisms rather than being
afraid of it there's a really cool quote
actually from
a rival school from the epicureans but
the stoics say some other things marxa
really says similar things to us
epicurus said something deeply
paradoxical he said in a philosophical
debate everybody wants to be the winner
right
but ironically the person who benefits
the most from a philosophical debate is
the person who loses the argument
and that's a beautiful paradox the guy
that wins the argument doesn't really
gain anything but the guy that loses the
argument potentially learns something so
epicurus is like why are you so
desperate to win like socrates actually
talks as if he wants to be refuted he
kind of wants to he wants other people
to disprove things because he thinks us
you know some of that's almost like
getting vitamins in your mind or
something like that is something
nourishing and healthy about that
i think the other thing that marcus
would say that's related to this and
this might surprise people
um unless they've just heard me saying
it lots already i think marcus would
find the intern the striking thing about
the internet is the amount of rage and
anger and hatred and spite and stuff
that's on it and passive aggressiveness
and things and the stoics
differ from modern psychotherapists
this has made me realize in a way this
is a shortcoming of my profession of
modern psychotherapy let me back up and
explain a little
the stoics thought that the may the
stoics did psychotherapy they straight
up just did psychotherapy they wrote
books called on therapy um some people
find that hard to believe like most of
those books are lost now apart from one
by seneca which is called on anger which
is a stoic therapy for anger and they
thought the most urgent emotional
problem to address was was anger
now usually we talk roughly of there
being three broad categories of negative
emotion anger fear and sadness
right so our anger
anxiety and depression if you like right
clinicians therapists mainly
predominantly see people with anxiety
disorders
and clinical depression
or some combination thereof
there might be bits of anger but people
that predominantly suffer from anger
tend not to seek therapy
right so therapy has a kind of
self-selecting audience to some extent
angry people think you need therapy
buddy like not me so they're less likely
to go and seek therapy where you see
angry people is in institutions like in
prisons in schools in the military
because somebody else says buddy you've
got an anger problem you need to go and
see a counselor or therapist about that
but angry people are generally resistant
to seeking help because they think
they're in the right there's a
righteousness about it they think
they're in the right i think for that
reason one of the risks of modern
self-help the internet is also a wash
with self-help self-improvement advice i
think the downside of that is that
people potentially focus all of their
attention
in the wrong areas and neglect
like the place where they're actually
wounded the most deeply so i'm surprised
how
little discussion there is
in self-improvement communities about
anger
like it kind of comes in but it's not
usually the main focus and often people
that talk about self-improvement do it
in quite an angry agree you know
surprising how hostile they can be in
their conversations like in youtube
comments and stuff like that
um
it's like that's where the biggest blind
spot is and for that reason i like to
call it the royal road to
self-improvement if people could just
get past that blind spot and realize
that's the biggest opportunity
like for actually transforming our
character because it's the most
neglected part of our personality and
the stoics knew that working on anger is
the biggest opportunity in anger i think
so what do you think the stoics would
say about dealing with depression and
anxiety
yeah they think those are equally uh
also very important areas like their
main focus is anger but they think
depression and anxiety are important as
well
um
the stoics i mean let's talk about some
specific things that i think are
actually helpful in practice i like to
chat and talk about trivia and things
but uh it's also good to just give
people some practical takeaways right
so
in terms of coping with anxiety there
are a bunch of things the stocks have
many many techniques actually um
one of them is you know we call it a
view from above
like this idea of broadening your
perspective they were so far ahead of
their time in comprehending this so they
would visualize the world as i've seen
from mount olympus or try and visualize
the cosmos as a whole
whenever they're talking about cosmology
in ancient philosophy in a sense of
visualizing the whole of time and space
marcus talks about this quite a lot as a
psychological technique in fact at one
point he says he does it every day if
you can imagine the effect of doing
something like that every day
now what i'd say about that is that
we know now that when people become
anxious or angry and also all depressed
they exhibit cognitive biases
and
usually we don't realize that we have
those biases because we're looking at
the world through the biases so it's
like the dunning-kruger effect like
we're too biased to notice our own
biases right
and so when people are anxious they
engage in threat monitoring as it's
sometimes called so they'll their focus
of attention becomes quite narrow and
quite selective and they'll look for
possible
they'll look for reasons to worry same
as angry people look for things to be
pissed off about like anxious people
look for things to be frightened of
right we it's easy to see other people
doing that right
i mean like when you look at other
people and they're anxious or angry you
think that guy's just looking for stuff
to get angry about it's obvious but we
don't realize when we're doing it
ourselves because we're kind of biased
we need other people to tell us that
we're looking at things in a really
biased very selective way
the stoics realized that when we broaden
our perspective spatially
chronologically it helps to counteract
this narrowing of attention that we tend
to see in extreme emotions
and
one of the dilemmas in modern
psychotherapy
is that when people have troubling
thoughts when they get upset they
usually go to one extreme or the other
so either they ruminate right so if
somebody has an anxious thought that
pops into their mind either they spend
way too much time going over and over
like we call that what the worrying
cognitive style so they'll go what if
this happens what if that happens how am
i going to cope with it what will i do
and they'll they'll get to sleep for
hours they'll be lying in bed at night
forever i was like thinking about it
right going round and round and round
circles or they do the opposite chris
and a thought pops in the mind
you know what if i go bankrupt what if
my wife leaves me or something
and they go i mustn't think about that i
have to block it from my mind so they
attempt thought suppression as we call
it and try and avoid thinking about it
so they either overthink it or they
avoid thinking about it and those are
both highly toxic ways of coping with
distressing information or ideas and
usually what happens is people kind of
ricochet back and forth between either
overthinking things or being extremely
avoidant and you see this all the time
and the the sad thing is there's got to
be a via media there has to be another
way a third option
and the third option is to allow
yourself
to acknowledge the information or the
thought but in a more detached way
and one way of doing that is by gaining
what we call cognitive distancing so
realizing it's just a kind of arbitrary
thought
like viewing it almost like from the
side like and go oh donald's telling
himself that he could go bankrupt so
donald's telling himself his marriage
could collapse or something like that so
you get a sense of objectivity about
your own thoughts by stepping to one
side and noticing them like that aaron t
beck the founder of cognitive therapy
said it's like you're looking at the
world through rose tinted glasses
or you know catastrophe tinted glasses
in this case and instead of looking
through them and just thinking that's
how the world looks it'd be like you
took them off and looked at them and
went oh i see now those are the lenses
that i was looking through
right but another way of doing something
similar is to broaden your perspective
and that allows you that's not avoiding
the thought you're still acknowledging
the thought
like and it's not over analyzing it and
going around in circles like you're not
really engaging with it you're just
shifting your perspective the key often
what both of those techniques have in
common is you continue to accept the
thought that you're shifting the
perspective that you have on it and that
allows us to avoid this overthinking at
one extreme or avoidant uh thought
suppression way of coping at the other
end that's a takeaway that i'd like to
kind of give people you know it's very
simple learn to accept upsetting
thoughts but from a different
perspective is that slightly more for
anxiety than depression or both
i think
what we know i mean i hesitate to say
these words because there's no panacea
but the closest thing that we have to a
panacea and modern research and
psychotherapy is cognitive distancing we
know that it works for anxiety and
depression and really a whole bunch of
different things and it functions these
strategies function in a slightly
different way for for different problems
um but they this is used in the
treatment of clinical depression it can
be used for anger as well now these are
pretty general purpose strategies
they're tied up with what we call the
modern of the past 20 years or so the
third wave in psychotherapy and
evidence-based research-based
psychotherapy and the move toward which
was influenced in part by buddhist
mindfulness meditation practices so let
me in very plain english
everybody would know
when you do mindfulness meditation and a
thought pops in your you're sitting
there cross-legged with your joysticks
chris and your beads on and all that and
uh
suddenly a thought pops in you're like
yeah your mind you suddenly think hang
on a minute
what if nobody likes me everybody hates
me or something like you know like
because random thoughts just pop into
our mind like that
like background noise when you're
meditating you wouldn't think
jeez what am i going to do about that
why is that is it something to do with
upbringing what caught like so then you
wouldn't be meditating anymore right and
you also wouldn't think i have to stop
thinking about that like get rid of that
thought like quite drink some whiskey or
take some drugs i was like let's can i
distract myself when you're meditating
you'd naturally think i have to
acknowledge that thought but then just
do nothing in response to it like like i
just allow it to pass through my mind
like the weather
like
and so it's natural when you're
meditating that you adopt a detached
perspective to intrusive thoughts and so
for that reason researchers were very
interested in studying that and looking
at other ways it could be utilized
um
in terms of broadening the perspective
i'll give you this is my favorite
cognitive therapy takeaway right
because like there are techniques we use
in therapy i used to train therapists
for a living like for a long time in the
uk
um
some of the techniques we get therapists
to do are pain in the ass to teach like
they're complicated and is some things
that some people find easier to do than
others and then those other techniques
we use in therapy that are so simple i
don't know why we don't teach them to
kids like they're like idiot proof
therapy techniques and one of them is
to say what happens next so especially
with chronic warriors
so when people worry
they'll think about feared catastrophes
in the future
and they'll keep replaying them over and
over in their mind but the weird thing
about it is they'll focus on the worst
part of an incident and you have to ask
yourself why do you choose to begin at
that point and end at that point it's
arbitrary right if you're thinking about
your future you could expand
the duration of the clip so that
encompasses weeks or months or years or
whatever but your amp
you amplify your anxiety if you focus
on
the setback or the worst part and then
you don't think about what would happen
after and you also prevent yourself from
planning coping behavior right so it's a
really dysfunctional thing to do it's
got to do with the editing of the video
if you like in your mind why would you
choose that time slice like that's
what's kind of pathological about it so
in therapy all we have to do is to say
well suppose
you
did go bankrupt
what would probably happen next
and then they might say well i'd sit at
home and i cry a lot
and then you say so suppose you'd go
bankrupt you sat home and you cried a
lot what would probably happen next
and the and then someone might say well
i'd have to start thinking of ways that
i could kind of start another business
or find a job or something like that
and they say okay suppose that you did
that then what would probably happen
next and you just keep asking that
question over and over it forces them to
broaden their chronological perspective
and usually that dilutes the feeling of
anxiety because they're now thinking
about not just the worst part but also
bets where they're beginning to move on
so the anxiety is reduced but it also
forces them to problem solve as we call
it and think of potential ways of coping
which is maybe something that they
hadn't really you know taken time to
think through previously so just keep
asking yourself suppose
even if that did happen what would
probably happen next and just nudge
yourself past that initial catastrophic
movie clip
i like the fact that you're kind of
front loading hedonic adaptation
into the mind right now
the
studies say that a year after someone's
become disabled or won the lottery
baseline happiness tends to go back to a
similar sort of level as it was before
i'm not sure
whether that's
how well uh researched and studied that
is but certainly in my life when i think
about when really good things have
happened or when really bad things have
happened after a long enough time span
life kind of
feels the same i ruptured my achilles uh
about two years ago yeah and
you know yeah the rehab period sucked
and it was boring or whatever but
there's actually points of the recovery
that i really enjoyed there was points
of the recovery where i got real senses
of satisfaction very very
good
feelings from making progress so
yeah it's like a double-edged sword well
you're doing something i think in a
sense there are two types of people in
the world right there are people that
learn from experience and people that
don't
like so there are people especially i
think i'm kind of being slightly glib
but i think once you kind of like reach
around about 40 you suddenly you know
you potentially sit down and kind of
look back on how your life has gone so
far
and and you kind of notice
patterns and things in retrospect and
that is fundamentally a kind of wisdom
and some people don't seem to do that
like they don't seem to do that at all
whereas other people very naturally like
you're doing we'll just review
so yeah i had this accident and then you
know how was it after and i kind of
adapted to and that's how things panned
out and then you start to realize well
maybe that's what's going to happen in
the future when i encounter other
setbacks well the bottom line is the
bottom line is that no matter what's
happened to you all of the fears that
you had all of the nightmares all of the
concerns and worry and sleepless nights
and all that stuff
anybody that's listening to this right
now
inevitably made it through that
challenge because they're here to listen
to this right now like you have proof
for however many years and decades
you've been alive on the planet that no
matter what the challenge was you
managed to get through it by the fact
that you're still here
yeah i mean another thing that we like
to do worry is one actually my
specialism is uh you mentioned anxiety i
specialize in treating anxiety disorders
as a therapist mainly in social anxiety
but other types of anxiety as well
and one of my favorite pieces of
research on worry is that when you get
people to keep worry diaries and just
write all the stuff that they're
freaking out about down like keep a
record of it and then you kind of review
it just for research purposes sometimes
the things that researchers do just to
gather information end up being
accidentally therapeutic so if we say
well what percentage of those things
actually happened or what percentage of
them were as bad as you thought they
were going to be people go oh
no actually most of it never happened
and like how much time like how many
hours have you spent over your life
worrying about stuff that ended up not
actually happening or if it did happen
you cooked better or it wasn't as awful
as you thought it was going to be and
people will go geez i had like a large
fraction of my life
light in retrospect has probably been
spent worrying about stuff unnecessarily
and when you have that realization chris
when the scales drop from your eyes like
and you you actually it's one thing
someone telling you that there's nothing
looking back in your life and going geez
yeah
loads of wasted time wasted years like
worrying about stuff that didn't even
happen
like it makes you feel differently about
the future and about things that are
worrying you in the present right
speaking about depression and anxiety
and stuff just how
crazy was nero
oh i mean like well first of all i'll
pre-face i'm always surprised when
people get upset on the internet it's
where they go to get upset about how
we can't be certain about a lot of
things in history and i think i thought
everyone took this for granted like this
is a premise of the conversation as we
can't really know 100 for sure right so
we're just basing on what survives and
stuff but personally i think nero was
pretty crazy like subsequent generations
of romans really vilified him i mean
marcus aurelius uses him as an example
of somebody who's crazy
a tyrant and just dominated by his own
anger and anxiety so he he uses nero as
like uh his code for that is like an
example of that
um i mean i think
nero was a car crash
and what one of the reasons was
nero
like kind of instigated the second
sophistic um he loved greek culture
and he wanted to be an actor famously
and
he would force people to come and
applaud him like they that he they
created a special cohort like of
soldiers like who would round people up
at these festivals that he held and
they'd stand around them with swords and
like they had to applaud nero on stage
like reciting poetry and things like
that i mean how
fascistic like is that it's like the
nuremberg rallies or something like that
we're gonna execute you unless you
applaud this terrible play that nero's
written or whatever right it's crazy
um but i think part of the craziness of
it is
you know people talk a lot actually
these days about narcissism like i mean
obviously it's always been a thing but
it's easy
one of the things that we've always
known is that narcissistic individuals
have a magnetism and charisma to them
often
and
that's true throughout history like so
nero was a raging narcissist
um of course like even from just what
i've told you right it's clear this guy
is a raging you know narcissist
and uh i think that's kind of part of
the craziness you become this is one of
the fundamental things that stories
really warn us against is being too
preoccupied with winning approval from
other people
like too preoccupied with what other
people think of us nero is the extreme
example of that going wrong so he's a
vulnerable narcissist not a grandiose
narcissist then based on what the
literature would say
yeah he ended up committing suicide was
it he's only 40 or something wasn't he
yeah he was relatively young
he became emperor when he was very young
when he was a teenager and so the the
romans would say one of the things that
concerned them is if uh
marcus was concerned about commodus also
being a very young emperor and he said
like this hasn't got a good track record
like and actually similar thing happened
to come with us the
the i always think there's kind of like
several ways that a roman emperor can
maintain power like it it's it's
difficult it's a challenge a daily
challenge for how do you hang on to
power in the roman empire um you could
be assassinated there could be a civil
war
so you need ideally you want the army to
love you and be on your side that helps
julius caesar had the army on his side
like that then he was an emperor he was
a precursor of the impulse but he like
he had the army on his side
um marcus released didn't have the army
on his side initially like he hadn't
served in the military but he seems to
have really won them over why by the end
like they seem to have come to really
revere him you you want to have the
senate on your side like some emperors
treated the senators like trash they
executed them like they had um purges of
them whereas like hadrian for example
had terrible purges where he persecuted
the senators
and marx aurelius saw themselves as
working alongside the senate more they
were viewed as almost like the senators
like you know
part part of that like um you know
sharing power with them and so on
if you don't have the senate on your
side and you don't have the army in the
side you need to have the general public
on your side and the way that people did
that in part was through almost turning
themselves into celebrities in ancient
rome and throwing expensive gladiatorial
contests that to like having tv shows
today also like reality tv they would
have these expensive public performances
festivals like games to try and kind of
win over the public and impress them and
i think everybody knew that was the most
toxic way to try to hang on to power
why because
like
the
popularity like that tends to be fickle
like uh people end up having to do stuff
that's not really anything to do with
running the state like these guys like
nero and comedy seem to kind of forget
like about actually running the state
and they become much more preoccupied
with appearances
um
and it usually leads to assassination
while i'm being overthrown in the end
and i think marcus would have been
horrified to realize the first thing
that cummins did when marcus died was he
abandoned the army like he alienated the
senate and he dressed up as a he dressed
himself up he put
he had the statues built of himself with
a
lion skin than the main lion like he was
uh pretending that he was good hercules
um
and you know he became a megalomaniac
like he he wanted to be able to worship
him and he went and fought in these
gladiatorial contests like you see in
the ridley scott movie
like he was desperate to like being a he
fought in the costume like being a
reality tv star or something like that
like did you see the disaster did you
see the netflix series i think it's
called roman empire
yeah with chrome of the center i
i must have watched each season of that
five times i
don't know how historically accurate it
is but it is so entertaining for me
that style of documentary that netflix
does they've done world war ii in color
and the great events of world war ii in
in in hd where you've got
archive footage or
um actors playing out what's going on
interspersed with um experts and
historians talking about it dude i could
i could
if that was all that was on tv i'd be
happy with that for the rest of time
it's so cool
i remember watching that and thinking
the dramatizations are often kind of
inaccurate in some ways but that doesn't
bother me because i think yes like it's
a dramatization i remember watching that
and thinking i kind of like the
dramatizations better than i like the
the talking head experts sometimes in it
like i kind of you know i thought some
of the things that they were saying i
didn't entirely um agree with
but i love watching things like that
when we were researching the graphic
novel i
i didn't read that i'd never read that
many graphic novels and so i sat down
and i thought i'm going to read look big
pile of graphic novels like and i
thought geez man my job sucks i've got
to go to library and just read comics
all day but
but i couldn't do it i found them kind
of tedious like i wasn't really i was
kind of struggling to get into it i've
never got into them either yeah and then
i thought what i need to do
is actually
sometimes you've got to approach things
in a slightly roundabout way so to
research our graphic novel i've watched
loads of movies
i rewatched loads of movies i watched
these kind of tv series that you're
talking about
um and i looked at them from the
perspective of how could we do something
similar in a comic book format so i
didn't get inspiration from other comics
i got inspiration much more from films
and tv series because you need to do the
same thing right you need to set a scene
where's the perspective where's the
camera where are the protagonists so on
and so forth what's the backdrop going
to look like
oh you can do i mean i think it's
possible to do a graphic novel i didn't
even realize this at first but of course
you can have a graphic novel where it's
just a bunch of uh stick men talking if
you really wanted
and you just don't below the dialogue in
it but at the beginning i thought we
can't do that right uh i really i don't
want to do that i want to
have a story about works of release
there's a lot of action
and i want to have philosophy in it but
where we can like try and weave it into
the action more like so actually if you
took all the philosophy out of it it
would still be a really cool story
like i don't want a bunch of like
stick men or a bunch of men in togas
just like talking to each other loads i
want this the philosophy to kind of
emerge from the action more
i started reading a guy called jed
mckenna last year and he's got a book
called spiritual enlightenment now so
he's a guy that says that he's awakened
and is basically speaking uh stream of
consciousness about what his life's like
he's running some sort of conventi type
thing in america and i really really
fell in love with it whether the guy is
awakened or not completely fully the um
separation of self from everything else
like all of that everything he's reached
it um whether that's true or not doesn't
really matter because the writing to me
is just so spectacular and in it he has
this concept that he calls releasing the
tiller and he talks about how when
you're in a boat the till is the thing
that's attached to the rudder it's what
you steer with and he talks about um how
most people grip the tiller very very
hard and uses this analogy in sailing
that if you're sailing through a storm
one of the best ways to actually
maneuver the boat is to allow the tiller
to maneuver itself because the boat will
find the easiest path up and over the
waves and he
keeps on talking about that and then i
had ryan holiday on last year and he was
i mentioned it to him and he was like
that's a lot like ammo fatty you know
sort of loving your fate about releasing
the till or allowing yourself to be sort
of carried a little bit more
and i never got to speak to ryan that
much about that concept although i did a
little bit of research so i wondered if
you could take me through
what i need to know about loving your
fate and and where it came from and and
what you your reflections have been on
it
because i've got two things that pop
into my mind immediately like and
one of them is about a trivia for you
but you asked me where does it come from
so that phrase comes from nietzsche who
was a we think of him as a philosopher
but he was a professor of classical
philology by profession like of ancient
languages
and as far as i know no one has ever
been able to trace that that phrase amor
fatigue to any surviving latin text
right so either it's a kind of like uh
phrase that nietzsche just coined
himself
um which sounds odd because it sounds
very similar so it really does sound
very similar to things that marcus
aurelius says so it couldn't sound more
stoic although nietzsche paradoxical as
he is often is kind of quick critical
historics it seems to really rip off
their ideas like really blatantly in
other ways right like so
after a long time i thought it's just
this thing that nietzsche come up with
and then i realized actually
although there's not a latin version
there's a greek version of that phrase
and uh
i think it's storge tikkun or something
like that in greek and it's in um
johannes stabias if i remember rightly
in the list of maxims that come from the
delphic oracle so people thought the
delphic oracle was a woman again another
weird paradox we think of greek
philosophy is mainly men the pathia the
priestess of apollo was a woman and the
god apollo supposedly spoke through her
like she was possessed by him or
something and we have all these maxims
there's like 160 odds that survive like
know thyself all things in moderation
and the famous ones
and one of them is love your fate
and plutarch who is a famous philosopher
but also a priest of apollo at delphi
right
he says the the pithia comes out with
these things that like koans
these most of them are two words in
greek
like
a very very condensed and he said but
people have written books about
philosophy many volumes long discussing
them so they'll exceeds that philosophy
grows out of and becomes very verbose to
go back to what we were talking about
earlier i mean normally it's the other
way around you take com marcus is taking
this complex philosophy and compressing
it into short phrases but plutarch says
she would just spit out these two words
and then people would go away and try
and figure out what they meant and come
up with like lots of different versions
for example um genotha i see autumn was
written engraved in the entrance to the
temple of apollo and people think it
means kind of mindfulness or like
investigating your own character and
stuff like that it's a kind of a
recurring theme and
you know
greek philosophy particularly in
socrates but seneca and plutarch both
say it's a memento mori
they say that know thyself means know
that you are
mortal
like because it's what you read as
you're walking into the temple of apollo
at the entrance before you're about to
be in the presence of the immortal god
apollo
like so remember that you're not an
immortal
blood it's not to do with introspective
work reflections it could be all of that
it could be both right so i guess that's
what plutarch is means as well is that
she just says something cryptic that
sounds really cool and some people take
it away to mean you've got to really
investigate yourself and explore a
character and other people say no it
means something completely different but
equally profound about remembering that
you are like finite and mortal and stuff
like that
so yeah like that's uh
i think it's really cool this idea that
people say our philosophy is dominated
by men but maybe it was a there was a
woman that was just kind of like
pressing the buttons and initiating it
all have you read the immortality key by
brian murarescu
the one about the cookie on like uh oh
here's another we're on our travia roll
no chris i'm fine did you know did you
know that marcus aurelius
had hardly been out of rome then he went
and fought
and
along the danube in
austria
um
hungary in these countries and then he
he eventually took the east of the
empire towards the end of his life and
he went to athens
and during the height of the war we're
told he made a vow that he was going to
go to
ellucis just outside athens and be
initiated into the alassanian mysteries
and that must have meant that he drank
the cookie on which is this small
quantity of liquid
which some people believe contains
something like ergot
like it's kind of precursor of uh lsd
because it's the cult of demeter the the
grain mother or the earth mother the
goddess of of wheat and grain and ergot
grows naturally on
wheat
um and so they believe that over the
centuries they created this
hallucinating hallucinogenic kind of
liquid based on our god that people
drank as part of the ceremony and it's
weird to think the markets are released
may have drank it
that's cool i mean i spoke to brian and
he
his work's fascinating he's such an
impressive guy i was in uh
uh guatemala about two months ago
picking up my american visa and i went
out for dinner with this guy that
watches the show and he's got a huge
youtube channel in
spanish
in spanish
and uh
he was telling me that um brian is
completely fluent in spanish
he
almost completely fluent in portuguese
he
is a full-time solicitor or some other
like some sort of lawyer law professor
and also is researching the
ellucian mysteries at the same time and
flying all over and going to athens and
trying to work out what's going on with
ergot and uh i was just really really
impressed with it what are your thought
do you think that this is legit do you
think that they would have had a
psychedelic brew that would have perhaps
been a a sacred ritual that many of the
philosophers of the day went to do a
tribute at
i don't know i'm kind of keeping an open
mind but i think it's like uncertain i
definitely think it's possible
um
and he says something actually that's
true which is generally
if you speak to people in greece they're
kind of more sympathetic to what they're
like yeah sure of course
like there's less of maybe less of a
stigma around it but i don't who knows
like whether it actually happened or not
we don't really know if when marcus did
that was almost certainly after he
finished writing the meditations oh yeah
that's that's something that we didn't
that we didn't quite clarify earlier on
so you mentioned that he's doing it when
he's in basically modern day austria
it's freezing cold but
what's the time period is it is this
uh for over a long span of time or is
this kind of condensed information that
you have you've got the meditations yes
um
like our best gay
i could
talk all day about the little bits of
evidence that contribute towards us
there are bits of evidence that we can
use to date the meditations within a
certain boundary like for example one
here's a cool bit of trivia like at one
point he says at conuntum which is the
main legionary fortress uh in modern day
austria on the danube now when i was in
i went to find him for a week doing
research and i spoke to the director of
archaeology there and i said have you
found any stuff here that might be
relevant to marxist release because
often archaeological remains don't tell
us that much about you know philosophers
theories and things like that right or
kind of like specific stuff that we get
from the text
but um they found a grave marker for a
praetorian god that's dated 171 a.d
and the praetorian gods were the
emperor's personal bodyguards so that
strongly suggests that marcus must have
been incommentum in 171 a.d which kind
of squares with other bits of evidence
that we have
so he says i'm in command and when he
wrote that in the meditations
it may have been round about that time
um
i mean specifically i think he probably
wrote it between roughly 170
and about 174 a.d
and then the civil war happened
and uh and i think that kind of marks
like the end of it roughly
is that not a bit of a shame the fact
that you know
marcus had
a bunch more life to live and
potentially lessons to accumulate that
aren't written down
yeah i think maybe he went and drank the
cookie on and thought
i've changed my mind about all this
stuff [ __ ] [ __ ]
well i mean it kind of looks like
especially the people say the view from
above they thought seems kind of trippy
and psychedelic like some of the
passages in the meditations they can't
imagine that he might have taken
hallucinogenic substances before he
wrote it
um
he took opium but it seems like it was
probably in quite small quantities
um
galen says he asked to reduce the dose
if remember rightly because it was
making him too drowsy he took it for
insomnia on uh
like a chronic uh chest and stomach pain
that he was suffering people thought he
had a
stomach also right
he may have like we're kind of guessing
but he talks about these pains and
spitting blood and stuff so he may have
had an also he was pretty frail there's
a later roman offer author that
describes him centuries later in
retrospect he says he had diaphanous
transparent skin
like so they certainly had this image of
him as being kind of
like very frail and like it's often the
case though isn't it sometimes there are
guys that are super fit and athletic and
then they drop dead like in the 30s or
whatever and then there's other guys
that are really sickly and frail and
they outlive everybody maracas was one
of these
warren buffett has a mcdonald's every
single day i think that's right that's
what he attributes uh his longevity
level of relaxation i'm not really too
sure so going back to the um amarfati
thing a lot of stoicism is built around
preparing for death how do you think
marcus
felt
as he was dying and as death approached
him
when i was writing the graphic novel one
of the things that changed about my
perception of marcus was uh i i just sat
up one day from working on it and i
thought
i just suddenly dawned on i thought this
guy must have really just woken up every
morning and kind of pinched himself and
thought
am i still alive
because everyone was dropping dead from
the plague
this kind of variant of smallpox we
believe it was the underlying plague
um he lost many friends and family
members he had 14 kids and half of them
died before him
he
frontal and rusticas died
he
he could have been assassinated at any
moment there was a civil war against him
and then he stationed himself in the
danube at a place where we're told 20
000 roman soldiers were killed in one
day and one of what would have been one
of the worst defeats in roman military
history but probably before he went
there so he was putting himself in
danger militarily as well it's like for
a bunch of reasons like so when he's
meditating on death in the meditations i
think it's interesting to realize
that he was just to put it bluntly in an
incredibly dangerous and precarious
situations this is awesome abstract idea
he's meditating on something that is at
the the forefront of his existence every
day i mean have you ever been in a
dangerous situation and and you you kind
of opinion you said geez like i actually
survived that like i feel like marcus
did that every day like he must have
thought wow i'm still here
you know i've survived many outbreaks
this horrible plague and stuff
so it wasn't at all abstract for him and
i and like the other weird thing is like
to say
because he was frail i think
people and because he was famous i think
he was surrounded by people waiting for
him to die he even taught he actually
talks about that a bit in the
meditations so imagine what it would be
like to
have people gossiping all the time but
when do you think he's going to die like
he's coughing all the time he looks
really frail he's going to kill over us
any minute like imagine that's all the
conversation that's going on around you
man like for decades
like and suddenly
meditation she's like i don't know maybe
they're right like
you know like maybe i'm going to kill
over any minute i i think he had
more opportunity than any of us to come
to terms with his own mortality okay so
let's say that you're a stoic and you're
meditating on death let's also say that
death is at the forefront of your
existence how how do you not descend
into a more hedonic
style of living
i think that's a really interesting
question um i mean my experience is that
that's not
what it leads to although i guess for
some people it can first of all let's
preface that by saying the stoics
thought that meditating on death would
lead you
to embrace reason
more as a guide to life
and i think
part of it
has to do with this kind of broadening
of perspective that we mentioned earlier
it comes from the fact that i think when
we contemplate
our own mortality what goes hand in hand
with that is thinking about our life as
a whole
rather than you know becoming too
preoccupied with
like moment-to-moment existence
when you're lying on your deathbed you
naturally tend to look back over your
life as a whole
why and i guess what the stoics are
doing is
this kind of paradoxical balancing act
where on the one hand they want us to be
really grounded in the present but also
kind of at the back of our minds also
have this expansive awareness of the
whole space and time they want us to
have our cake and eat it chris
like they want us to be grounded in the
present but also aware of the totality
of existence as the context within which
the present moment takes place and i
think that changes the way that we
perceive transient pleasures let me
explain why i'm going to say something
that i think is very profound
because marcus everybody says it right
there are many things over the years
that i've learned in philosophy and
psychology and some of it sounds what
i've learned is some of the things that
sound really deep and profound are
usually bs
by and not that deep you know when you
kind of dig into them but then you know
often the most profound things are kind
of relatively simple
marcus talks at one point about how
when
people desire things in a sense what
they're doing is imagining the presence
of something that's currently absent
what if i had a really nice car i don't
have a really nice car but i'm imagining
work to like if i didn't have one it's
hypothetical he says everyone does
account actually but he says what if you
do the opposite and you imagine the
absence of things that are currently
present then rather than desire you
experience gratitude right it's a cool
neat little rhetorical way of putting it
right
but
there's also something about deeper
going on there
because
if we expand our perspective so we
acknowledge a broader context
then in addition to experiencing the
presence of the things that we currently
have at the back of our mind or at the
periphery of awareness we have to
acknowledge there was a time before
and there will be a time after
this experience
like so we experience the presence and
absence of something simultaneously
by broadening our perspective sure i
haven't now
like but there was a time when i didn't
have this and one day it will be gone
like one day i'll be gone so we
experience the presence the pure
presence of the present moment but
enveloped in this kind of nothingness
or absence of individual things but also
of our entire life
and i think that when we broaden our
perspective and we experience presence
and absence of ourselves and the things
we're enjoying
simultaneously it dilutes the intensity
of our emotional experience i mean that
in a good way it kind of
brings it within rational bounds
i would say
like and it's the same like if you're
experiencing pain or discomfort
like our pleasure allows you i think
that perspective allows you to enjoy
pleasure without being
consumed by it like our um
you know without uh
becoming uh too much of an indulgence
without losing perspective i guess
that's a good way phrasing it allows us
to keep perspective
on the things that are causing us pain
or pleasure naval ravikant says that
desire is a contract you make with
yourself to be unhappy until you get
what you want
yeah come like the stoics kind of say
that as well
um they talk about as being and in
modern psychology
this is the formula really for anxiety
it's future focused
like we the anxiety
fear is the belief that something bad is
going to happen
like although we're going to be deprived
of something that we desire and a lot of
fear is predicated on the stuff that we
we value like you say you know so in
terms of society um most people that
live in the first world are full of
consumed with anxiety about losing stuff
that our parents never had to begin with
you know like when i was a kid growing
up i love being able to see this now you
know like uh we used to walk to school
in the snow with no shoes and all that
you know like when i was a kid
everything was made of wood and cost two
pens like back in the days but when i
was a kid growing up in scotland we
really didn't have that much we didn't
have the internet you know like
if i wanted to get books that were hot
it was hard to obtain books on
philosophy in the small town that i
lived in
and now we can take more and more stuff
for granted but we also live in abject
terror of being deprived of these things
whereas you know
it would just bring us back back to the
level of people throughout most of human
history who are fairly content
not to have
central heating and the internet and the
microwave oven and all this kind of
stuff
like we we becoming overly attached to
these things we really set ourselves up
for fear and anxiety and depression it's
crazy how you see people who are very
wealthy and successful and then they
lose it and commit suicide and you think
but you still have more money than the
majority of people by
more opportunity and more success
like it's just that you had a relative
loss in status
the stoics want us to try and see
through that and transcend it i think
speaking of rich powerful people has
canceled culture tried to come for
stoicism yet i mean it's a rich white
person elitist
uh philosophy i love all this stuff in a
way i just kind of find that like most
things i think the key to life is
paradox isn't it the key is to kind of
like i said before about how can we
accept a thought but without you know
getting entangled with it so there's got
to be like a third way i think we have
to be able to laugh at some of this
stuff but also kind of take it seriously
at the same time you know you can't you
don't want to get too seriously you
don't want to laugh at it too much but
like there's kind of a
a middle road i mean i think some of
it's kind of absurd right the stoics
usually what people say is like the
opposite of the truth so the stoics were
famous for in ancient greece anyway as a
foreign philosophy like they were the
immigrants
um zeno was shipwrecked he was
phoenician
like um
he's described as having
dark skin
um
like even the word that you actually use
is black but it probably just means that
he was quite dark-skinned he was
perceived as foreign
like very foreign and his philosophy was
perceived as a foreign import to athens
he was a medic legally like a a a
permanent resident or a foreign
immigrant at athens he wasn't an
athenian citizen and most of the
subsequent teachers came from what we
described as the middle east now from
asia minor
um
so this idea that it's kind of
these this dominant tradition of white
men is just historically not really
accurate
um
you know like it's it's if you really
visualize what was going on it's a
philosophy of immigrants and people who
were looked down on by the athenians
because they were foreign
athens
um
so it's just not factually
accurate to begin with
um
it's how i see it i ironically
well i
pretty much everything is going to be
trampled by the cancel culture mob at
some point so i'm sure that you'll uh
you'll probably have to defend some of
the the boundaries of stoicism
and the other thing they tend to say is
it's a philosophy for the roman elite
which is kind of there's a grain of
truth in that there's more truth first
of all there's both more and less truth
in that than they realized so first of
all marcus i realized was elite but they
don't realize also that augustus the
founder of the roman empire was into
stoicism as well like so marcus wasn't
the only emperor that was into stoicism
and the others kind of like dabbled in a
bit as well like nero obviously and
hadrian although they weren't really
stoics themselves as such but stoicism
was like also a philosophy of poor
people certainly at one point clianthi
is the second head of the stoic school
what are gardens at night for a living
like really
cheap manual labor that he did he was
notoriously poor
um he used to be a professional boxer
like so he was this kind of uh
you know
example of uh a poor working-class dude
lie that became a famous philosopher an
epictetus was a former slave as well
obviously and the cynics as well lived
like beggars basically so the idea that
it's just a philosophy for the roman
elite is just contrary to the historical
facts basically the roman elite liked it
but it was also embraced by
you know
poorer people in the slave class even
speaking about the higher class people
what do you think marcus would say about
not getting seduced by fame
oh he says a lot about that
i mean i think it was his fear gosh
there's a whole there's a really
interesting story there chris but i'll
just be able to kind of touch on it
briefly here when i read there are many
biographies of marcus that release and i
think generally they don't pay enough
attention to hadrian like i talk a lot
more about adrian um when i and the
biography that i've written about marcus
and i think one reason for that is the
hadrian was suggested by fame
like he was absolutely preoccupied with
his kind of
wanting to be
revealed as an intellectual actually and
as a poet
um
and he kind of went crazy towards the
end um became a tyrant
and i think marcus really was frightened
at first of becoming
adopted into the imperial family and one
day becoming emperor because he thought
i don't want to end up like hadrian
like on the one side he's like it's all
sycophants that are like sucking up to
him and telling him whatever on the
other hand it's all just people plotting
to assassinate him like and he's kind of
like caught in the middle of this kind
of gradually going bonkers like cooked
up in this massive opulent
part like luxury palace that he's
created for himself surrounded by slaves
and stuff and marcus thought this is
just gross
like it's a car crash and i don't want
anything to do with it and then luckily
for him he was too young to become
emperor so hadrian adopted a kind of
interim ruler uh antoninus pie it's
actually ruled for 23 years like
probably longer than most people
expected because he he he lived a long
time he died in the 70s i think
and marcus had this really long
apprenticeship 23-year apprenticeship
under anthony's bias and i think he had
this big revelation he was the opposite
of hadrian in every regard basically and
antonio this guy isn't corrupted by
power the first thing he did was he he
moved into a somewhat more modest
palace of building uh compared to this
crazy massive thing that hadrian had
constructed and he
um he got rid of a lot of the
furnishings and starches he went around
dressed in a senatorial robes which
would be like instead of wearing like
purple like kind of regalia like a
monarch antoninus pius basically wore
the modern equivalent of a business
like
and he adopted a kind of more
presidential
role as the as the emperor and marcus
saw this and thought wow this couldn't
be more different from hadrian i think
that inspired him to think maybe there's
a way
but i think i think his challenge you
know i mean you you've read the
meditations
in book one he talks about 17
different people they're all family
members or tutors that he's trying to
role model he's listing their vouchers
and
antoninus pious he says far more about
than about anyone else
i think marcus
this is decades after antonina's died
marcus was obsessed with modeling
his adoptive father partly because he
lost his birth father when he was very
young so he was kind of craving a father
figure and in between he had seen these
terrible negative role models right and
so he latched on to antennas says his
savior on her way he thought this is a
guy that i actually respect and he
provides the template for how to not
turn into adrian why and and how to be a
ruler and i think marcus thought how can
i become like antoninus and avoid
turning into hadrian and the answer to
that question is stoicism he thought i'm
going to train in stoicism and that way
that will help me to become more like uh
antoninus and less like hadrian
donald robertson ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with the
courses you do and get the new graphic
novel and stuff where should they go
my website's just donald robertson dot
name name so if they want to check that
out i've got stuff all over social media
and things that they can have a look at
fantastic donald i
always love speaking to you and next
book next year as soon as it's ready let
me know i want to bring you back on
awesome thanks very much chris it's been
a pleasure as always what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace
you